good evening everyone welcome to the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences governor's Awards this is a
tenth anniversary of these honors is a
free-standing
the event separate from the annual Oscar
show on November 14 2009 filmmakers
Roger Corman Gordon Willis and Lauren
Bacall were presented with the Oscar
statuette and John Calley received the
Fahlberg award at this first show the
honorary and special Oscars date back
long before they became the governor's
awards back even to the first Academy
Awards dinner a few blocks from here at
the Hollywood Roosevelt Hotel where
Warner Brothers Studio received a
statuette for producing the jazz singer
the Pioneer talking picture which has
revolutionized the industry in 1934
Shirley Temple received the first in a
series of miniature statuettes given to
juvenile stars five years later for Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs Walt Disney
received a full-size statuette with
seven miniatures on a stepped base you
can see it today and Walt's office on
the Disney lot if they'll let you in
and just last year the governor's
awarded a special Oscar to Alejandro in
the auditor and you mine you Alou bets
Keys deeply moving virtual reality film
pattern a yo Dania these honorary and
special awards have always been a very
changeable feast Buster Keaton Lillian
Gish Akira Kurosawa Federico Fellini
Stan Laurel Robert Redford Silesia Dre
and Andrew Vajda
are a few of the many great artists
whose singular Oscar is dis honorary
award and the decades before Academy
governors created this tribute evening
the recipients of the Thalberg the
Herschel and honorary Oscars received
their awards during the academy award
ceremony over the years of feeling grew
that our legends of cinema deserve a
brighter spotlight one solely there is
one that allows their peers to pay
greater tribute and for us to know them
better
these annual awards have become a
celebration second only thought the
night itself there have been many
changes during the Academy's 91 years so
many just in the past few years as you
all know some have been readily embraced
some have been challenged this is
because the Academy is and always will
be a dynamic organization ready to
embrace the new and the necessary always
looking to the future this is a
testimony to all of you here tonight and
to the men and the women representing
the Academy 17 branches will all of our
governor's please stand so we can thank
you for your dedication
commitment to the Academy its mission
[Applause]
last Saturday night I spoke at the
opening of the Cameron Hodge Festival
and polling the lifetime achievement on
read was the great polish
cinematographer V told Silva Kinski
there were recorded video tributes from
Polish American cinematographers Janusz
Kaminski and arias Wolski
Darrius spoke from the spacious living
room of his home in Point Dume but even
as we watched the video
Darius's home and his personal and movie
records and Archives burned to the
ground in the Wolsey fire there are
sadly so so many stories like Daria says
some of our own history was lost when
the same fire damaged the Paramount
ranch home to the Academy's decades-long
summary screenings of silent films this
devastating fire so close to our own
homes and those of our friends has
bonded us in a special way not just with
them but beyond was the survivors of the
Northern California campfire that
destroyed the town of paradise many
thousands of our fellow Americans are
homeless living in tents nearly 1,400
people are still unaccounted for our
loving thoughts go to all those affected
there and here and our thanks to the
firefighters and first responders many
still on the front lines
it's light we can demonstrate our
support for those affected by the fires
of the past few weeks when you reach out
to offer them assistance please be
generous we want to thank Rolex for
their generous commitment and
partnership here this evening
they've been a long-standing champion of
arts and culture we at the academy are
grateful for their year-round support of
our programs and of our upcoming Academy
Museum excitement
excitement continues to build around the
world for the museum's opening and this
week our great architect Renzo Piano has
been meeting with us overseeing the
construction progress tonight is my
second Governor's Award as your
president and once again I am deeply
honored to be part of this celebration
which recognizes five of our art forms
icons I will leave it to our presenters
to give each recipient their proper
accolade but I do want to honor each one
now by name congratulations to the great
publicist and longtime board member
[Applause]
Marvin I think you have a few friends to
the musical poet of so many classical
movies Lalo Schifrin
to the unparalleled iconic actress miss
Cicely Tyson
and to the eminent wife and husband
producing partners Kathleen Kennedy and
Frank Marshall
in paying tribute to them we recall what
first drew us to the movies what makes
us remain so passionately dedicated to
our community it's really very easy we
love the movies how they define us how
they inspire and change us how in an
ever more divided world our movies unite
us in a greater human community by an
appreciation of our art and the artists
who created so here he's early this time
so here to our honorees this evening a
toast and one also to our beloved
Academy thank you have a great evening